Evet Hayal kurmak dedik Hayaller
kitabında saklı dedik gelin sizinle
tatlı bir hayal kuralım bu hayal çok
uzak değil biz istanbullular için
Beşiktaşlı olsun Beşiktaş'ta
uzun bir arkadaş
ınızım Çay Simit sohbet güzel vakit
geçirdiniz akşama doğru ayrılma zamanı
geldi anadolu yakasına geç
ecek çeyrekli saatlerde Kalkan vapuru
yakalamak
şanslıysam diyorsunuz eski tip bir vapur
olur ayağımı şöyle delirdi koyarım
saçlarımın arasından rüzgar'ı geçiririm
takarım kulağıma da
Kulaklığımı belki Sezen'den Ah
İstanbul'u dinlerim ve koşturmaya devam
ediyorsunuz Tabii bu hayalin pek çok
versiyonu olabilir Bir başka versiyonu
belki Galata'dan başlayabilir
Eminönü'nde balık ekmek yiyebilirsiniz
belki Moda'da çayınızı içersiniz
bitirebilirsiniz bir başka versiyonunda
belki Marmara adalarına açılmak
isteriz rotanızı
yerine Köprüler tarafından feribot
tarafına
kulağınıza da sedefi değil Belki de
martılarını sesini almak istersiniz
onları silip de beslerken böyle güzel
hayallerin ortak zeminde tahmin ettiniz
Ali abi de söyledi zaten Ortak zeminimiz
Marmara
Deniz ben biyolog değilim daha koyayım
Bilmem bir Şnorkel takmayı öğrenmem çok
Zaman Aldı Dün prova'da bunu takmayı
becermem çok Zaman Aldı
maalesef de başladı maalesef
müsilajla başladı Haberinizi çok severim
denizde iyileşirim o ayrı ama Denizli
Sefer bey gibi kafaya takma durumu
Çünkü bir sabah uyandık karşımıza çıkan
görüntü bizi bizden aldı Bir Çığlık da
aslında sessiz Bir Çığlık Bir yükselen o
çığlığı Ben duymamazlık edemedim Neden
Çünkü ben ailemi Ezgi Küçük Ben bir
stratejiste ve sürdürülebilirlik
uzmanıyım ama bu seste kulak vermeme
sebep olan bunların hiçbiri değil Biraz
disk eksik olmaz
[Müzik]
Bazen zaman alıcı şeyler de olabiliyor
yani otobüs durağında veya havalimanında
sanki oranın uzman
gelip yol sorulduğu bile olabiliyor ve
ben de cevap verebiliyorum bu da çok
Şaşır
tıcı geçen bir dönemde
Ben aslında ondan silebilsek diyorum
disleksik Hayat biraz böyle arkadaşlar
kelimeler harfler her şey yer
değiştirebiliyor ve hayatı böyle büyük
bir vakum içinde yaşıyorsunuz
Ama hiçbir şeye engel değil Ona rağmen
yol almak da mümkün ama keşke maalesef
ve Keşke ve rağmen demeden yol alabil
Neden Çünkü bu kelimeler
bizi kaostan kurtulmaya yardım eden
kelimeler değil
kelimeler ipin ucunu bulsak
çıkabileceğimiz o yerde kalmamızın sebep
olan kelimeler
Bir Temmuz ayında
hafızasının bileşenleri olarak Bizler de
o Hafızanın diğer canlıları kadar bir
yaşam hakkına sahip insanlar olarak
uyandığımızda çirkin bir görüntüden
duyduğumuz huzursuzlukla denize bakar
olduk ve hemen
Ne oldu denizanaları dedikleri yabancı
gemilerde de başkaları her şeyde bir
ötekinde ararız ya bizi suçu
tam olarak Bilemedik
Ne oldu ve biliyorsunuzdur artık belki
plankton denilen göz
le gör minnacık canlıların
keşfettik platform mu mini minicik
canlılar mı ve nasıl görünür oldular o
zaman bu köpükler nasıl ortaya çıktı çok
basit plan tonlar
aynı Deniz mercanları gibi aynı pinalar
gibi bu dünyada eşsiz yerlerini
bilincinde olsunlar olmasınlar o eşsiz
yeri çok iyi tutan canlılar nedir eşsiz
yerlere
günde
nerede ne işe yaradıklarını bilmeselerde
o devinimin o sihirli biyolojik kimyasal
sürecin
büyük bir oyuncusu var o mini minnacık
halleriyle ne yapıyorlar biliyor musunuz
sizin benim için oksijen üretiyorlar Ha
biz insanlar çok üstün canlı
larız yani Her şey bizim için modunda
olduğumuz için bizim için oksijen
üretiyorlar cümlesi size tuhaf gelmemiş
olabilir gelsin o canlılar bizden daha
aşağı değil bizden daha az değerli
değil ama baktığınızda biz onların
Değerini çok iyi
binacık canlılar
Peki atıkları ve denizin kendi kendini
temizlemek iyileştirme o besin zinciri
içerisinde yaşama alan açmak için bir
gayretleri var bu şekilde çalışıyorlar
azot fosfo fosfor nitrat yükünü alıp onu
denizin ihtiyacı olan bileşenlere
çevirme fikrine sahipler Peki bu hale
nasıl geldiler
bir araya gelerek Hani Biz bir araya çok
kolay gelemiyoruz ya özellikle pozitif
etkisi yaratmak konusunda böyle bir
konumuz var Şu ana kadar dinledik bunu
güzel örneklerini işte onlar bu sessiz
çığlığı ortaya çıkarmak için
bir araya geldiler atıkları temizlemeye
Çalışırken o büyük stresi baş edemeyip
öldüler ve bu aslında
uyanma
uyanma uyanma
gereken
geçen sene Temmuzdan bu yana kimden ne
öğrenebilirsem bu süreçte çözüm ortağı
nasıl olabilirsem ve de benimle beraber
çözüm ortağı kimler olabilecekse onları
sürecek tatmaya başladım ve Aslında
müsilaj Marmara Denizi benim için bir
öğretmen oldu benimle birlikte şu anda
gönüllü çalışan yaklaşık 60 70 arkadaşım
içinde öğretmen oldu Biz gördük ki
daha çok canlılar
[Müzik]
Akdeniz'de büyük bir ısınma durumu var
dedi hocamız Evet Marmara Denizi de ne
yazık ki iklim krizinden diğer yerlere
göre daha fazla etkileniyor kendi eşsiz
özelliklerinden kaynaklı bir sebeple
durağan bir deniz olması ve hiç Deniz
olması sebebiyle ama her
zaten karşı karşıya
tahmin edebileceğiniz gibi
çakılarla
[Müzik]
biz bu Olimpik Havuz kadar bir silaj
toplandı şu anda hala derinlerde ve
denizin nefes almasını engelliyor
Paradoks gibi İronik bir şey nefes
alamayan bir deniz bizim Aslında her
nefesimizden birini aldığımız bir yer
kendisi boğulmakta peki bunun sebebi
nedir baktığımızda 25 milyon insanın
İstanbul ve diğer dillerle birlikte
denize bıraktığı her türlü açık
diyebilirim Evinizde kullandığınız
bulaşık deterjanı şampuandan tuvaletin
sifonlu çektiğiniz noktada bizden her
şey denize karışıyor ve bunu sadece bir
kısmı biyolojik
çok çok küçük bir kısmı da ileri
biyolojik arıtmaya tabi ama mesele zaten
bizim kendi yaşamımızda tıpkı o
platformlar gibi doğada hiçbir şeyin çöp
ve atık olmadığı
ile yaşamayı öğrenmemiz için bize
verilen bir
diğer bir atık türü şaşıracaksınız ben
çok Şaşır
Mıştım sarımsal uygulamalardan gelen
kimyasal gübre ve ilaç pestisit
uygulamasının hem aşırı olması toprağa
ve suyu kirletmesi çiftçilerin Zaten
sağlık durumlarını buğday Derneği
sürekli Açıklıyor
kendi gıda sistemimizde kendi maruz
kaldığımız zehire bile o planktonların
bir araya gelip uyarı yaptığı gibi bir
araya gelemedik yani Belki de bizim
artık başka bir yola gitmek birlikte bir
yola gitmek için duymamız gereken izin
istediği dua aynı zamanda
İnstagramda ve diğer sosyal medyada bol
bol görüyoruz artık anne sütünde
akciğerde kanımızda plastik dolaşıyorken
Biz hala o tek kullanımlık şeyleri
elimizde tutmanın Çok havalı bir şey
olduğunu zannediyorum Oysa Aslında
denizin de doğası ve bizim de doğamız o
tek kullanımlık şeylerle değerli hale
gelen şeyler değil Çünkü biz Aslında
1960'larda başlayan bu bölgeye olan
büyük insan akınıyla Taşı Toprağı Altın
İstanbul ve Marmara
denizi mantığıyla biz ne yaptık Denizi
denizin alanını çağırdık
bu sevdiğim bir görsel Dün diğer
konuşmacılardan biri ailecim bunu belki
sunumuna eklemek isterseniz dedi ve
bayıldım bunu Orkinos Bey diye
geçtim ben şimdi size sormak istiyorum
Zafer Bey'e de gösterdi balık türlerinin
yoğunluğunu Sizce bizim eşsiz Marmara
denizimiz de Kaç tür balık vardır yünden
fazla diyenleri görebilir miyim
Evet
60-80 arası bir yerdedir diyenleri
görebilir miyim ışıklarda bana doğru ya
Sıkı kaldırırsan ancak görebilirim aynen
öyle gör
[Müzik]
ebilir miyim fındadır diyenleri
görebilir miyim
ön sıraya bakabilirsiniz Evet Aynen
bugün mü yaptınız buraya
Evet şöyle söyleyeyim Bu salonda şu anda
bu soruya yanlış cevap veren yok Çünkü
bir zamanlar Efendim Burası zaten biraz
önce hızlı geçtim ama dünyanın eşsiz
Deniz özelliği taşıyan Marmara
denizimizin 7 tane özelliği var çok zor
büyüyen türleri büyütmek nadide bir
ortam sağlamak gibi 7 tane özellik 7
özelliği 7 doğallık biz bu doğallığı
insanlar olarak kaybettirmiş durumdayız
ve o yüzden şu anda bazı hocalarımız
sadece 7 tür balık kal
düşünün artık
şimdi bu
haberimden sonra
Biz gerekiyor
yorumlusu Marmara deniz
i'nin ki su kim ve ne
[Müzik]
İnşaat atıkları var İnşallah biz
denizin ana Sürekli onun elinden
alıyoruz ormanların yaşamadan da onların
elinden alıyoruz tarımsal atık var
belediye aşırı Balıkçılık bunların
hepsini çıkardığımızda
mutlu ve sorunlu aramaya başladığınızda
bir yere varamayacağımızı anladık
Sırp laktonların bundan suçlu olmadığını
anladığımız noktada bu ayılma geldi
çünkü Bakın şu enfes görüntü şu Şahane
şey denizde güzel açık temiz Ferah Bir
denizde gece ellerinizi şöyle koysanız
elinizin üzerinde göreceğiniz harika
görsel bunun adını bilen var mı
duyamadım
yakamı Evet Ali abi bildi acaba neden
acaba
[Müzik]
gün içinde izlediği için inşallah
diliyorum ki bütün denizlerimizi
temizlensin ve Sizler ve dinleyen herkes
Yakamozlar İçinde yüzme fırsatı bulsun
Çünkü bu yakamızı yapan da müsilajı
yapan planktonlar fitoplanlar
Dolayısıyla elma çekirdeğini nasıl
gördüğünüz ile ilgili her şey ben onu
onu uygular Denizi bir ağaç kökleriyle
toprağa suyu ve yapraklarıyla havayı
temizleyen bir yaşam aracı olarak
görmeyi seçebilirim bir çöp olarak
görmeyi seçebilirim kendimi de aynı
şekilde elimi değdiğim yerde bıraktığım
etkiyi bakmaya başlayabilirim ona
bakmayı seçebilirim
anlayabilirim ve ondan sonra adımlarımı
ona göre atabilirim kul hakkı hep
başkasından bakarız kul hakkına girme en
çok kendi hakkımıza giriyoruz
disleksiyim kitap yazamam Çok hassasım
toplumsal meselelerle uğraşamam aşırı
heyecanlıyım 15 dakikada konuşmayı
bitiremem Ben Deniz diyaloğu değilim
Bunu anlatacak başka hocalarımız var
değil mi neler neler kendimizi durdurmak
için binlerce İnanç
Ama bakın bir arı kendini durdurmak için
bir inanç bulma o küçücük haliyle
dünyadaki yaşamı dönmesinden sorumlu
doğru mu Ödümüz patlıyor arılardan
ne işe yarıyorum bu dünyada sadece
tüketmek mi benim görevim Bir karınca Ne
muhteşem bir varlık muhteşem olmaya mı
çalışıyor Hayır
karıncalarını biliyor Ben dünyada insan
olarak
çıkartıyorum Hatta aile olarak
nasıl bir yer tutuyorum bir gün goncası
kokmaktan vazgeçer mi kendini ortaya
koymaktan vazgeçer mi onu dna'sında var
o ama biz sürekli belli bir kalıba
kendimizi sokmak belli bir şekilde
yaşamak için
zorluyoruz kendimizi Bu da tatlı kuşumuz
Google kuşu
Kuşlar Yani ben size kaybettiğim
nesillerin sayılarını vermiyorum ama
kuşlar dünyadaki yaşamı çok
destekleyen diğer canlılar gibi önemli
bir ne kadar kuş
[Müzik]
görüyorsunuz mercanları onlar da biraz
önce Zafer üstü anlattı
Denizi Deniz mer
canları
Biz de parçası olduğumuz yaşamın
içerisinde değerini anlamak için Biz bir
yola çıktık Son bir dakika ve artık etki
çemberleri Vakfı olarak kurumsallaştık
yapmak istediğimiz şey şu iyi örnekleri
bulup çoğaltmak Çünkü bir araya gelmeyi
Yakamoz yapmak için becermemiz lazım bu
silaj için değil ve bizim dörtlü bir
çerçevemiz var bazı şeyleri daha çok
yapmalıyız bazı şeyleri artık
yapmamalıyız Bazı şeylerin azaltıp bazı
şeyleri de arttırmalıyız bu döngüsel
ekonominin prensiplerini bu şekilde
çalışıyor Hani Balıkçıya ekonomiden Ee
anlatmışlar ya çok hoşuma gitti Yani
banka ve para üzerinden doğayı
anlatıyoruz kendi içimizdeki doğayı da
bizim bir parçası olduğumuz duayı da
anlamak için ekonomiyi kullanıyoruz
paradoksa bak
Biz Ekon Canlar değiliz ekolojik
canlarız kendi canımızın da diğer
canlıların da hakkını veriyor olmamız
gerekiyor
mantıkla 5 Paydaş üzerinden gittik
bunların fotoğrafını çekebilirsiniz
okuyacak Tabii ki değilim
[Müzik]
diyor zaten değil mi Hayır her birimiz
birer vatandaşız sivil toplum dediğiniz
de bizi belediye dediğimiz de bizi
devlet dediğimizde bizi hepimizin bu
ortak bilince gelmesi gerekiyor şimdi
size soruyorum Bir silajını yakam
Bu kadar basit ve
Belki de bir balkonla geldim duvar tadı
Hemen bak hemen okutanlar var
aslında gösterebilirsiniz
[Müzik]
silaj mı Yakamoz mu
burada Seçim yapıp Bugün güzel bir
resminizle
durmak üzere bize katılarak Siz de
gösterebilirsiniz eski çemberleri nokta
orgda gönüllü olabileceğinizi
bulabilirsiniz teşekkür ederim